as histórias inspiram histórias
connecton histórias trazem mudança
histórias curam há 11 anos atrás com
muita vontade de ajudar a transformar o
mundo tá melhor a gente fundou a maria
farinha filmes nosso objetivo era fazer
um áudio visual inovador que ajudasse a
trazer ferramentas para que essa mudança
acontecesse veja então a gente fez
filmes sobre obesidade infantil o
excesso de publicidade da criança
inclusão social educação novas políticas
refugiados dentre muitos outros
o nosso ponto de partida sempre foi o
que tá mais incomodando o que agora
precisa urgentemente de uma ferramenta
audiovisual para que a gente ajude a
melhorar alguma coisa ambiente falava
muito forte isso foi em 2012 já existiam
muitos documentários falando sobre o
ambiente muito documentários muito bons
mas a gente queria falar com além das
pessoas que assistem documentário a
gente precisava fazer uma ficção a gente
precisava entrar dentro da casa de cada
um através do intretenimento e do
coração com isso a gente ter uma ideia a
gente sabe tanto do que acontece no
hospital porque a gente assiste grey's
anatomy pior sob pressão a gente sabe
tanto do que acontece na casa branca
norte-americana por causa de west wing
por causa de house of cards e se a gente
fizesse uma série de ficção
eu contasse a vida de ativistas
ambientais dentro de uma ong ambiental a
gente achou que era uma grande ideia com
isso a gente começou a entrevistar as
pessoas foram mais de 50 entrevistas em
profundidade com ativistas do greenpeace
wwf alana dentre outros a gente percebeu
ali conta batalha contra luta quanto
conflito existia para que cada ativista
seguisse na sua luta e assim nasceu a
série aruan nas que em tupi-guarani
significa sentinelas para nós sentinelas
da natureza aruan nas conta a história
da vida de três amigas que se conheceram
na infância elas estavam para que elas
amavam muito um parque de muita reunião
encontro que estava sendo ameaçado de
virar um estacionamento elas foram
resilientes persistentes e ficaram ali
ocupando aquele pati até que elas
venceram a batalha
há alguns anos depois depois de formadas
elas resolveram fundar juntas aonde
aruana como objetivo de proteger a
natureza uma delas é a verônica a
verônica mais divulgada brilhante
advocacia em brasília para quem não sabe
é uma lobista do bem controladora ela
não conseguir controlar o seu coração e
se apaixonou pelo marido da jornalista
natalie sua grande amiga natalie essa
mulher profunda reservada ela perdeu uma
gravidez avançada e guarda um segredo um
luto patológico dessa gravidez perdida
enquanto isso a milhão na emissora onde
ela trabalha ela tenta emplacar suas
faltas ambientais a luísa destemida
corajosa é uma ativista de campo que que
ela faz ela se divide entre tentar
ajudar aqueles que têm a sua terra
contaminada a sua terra devastada sua
terra tirada dela e o grande desejo de
ser mãe do ian para ele ela fala o
propósito sempre tem que se
e eu tenho medo essa história foi criada
e roteirizada por mim e pelo meu sócio
marcos nisti e foi um desafio muito
grande para nós porque a gente pensava
como fazer uma série ambiental que não
parecesse didática então a gente usou
muitos recursos a gente usou recursos de
cenas de ação segredos e mentiras
múltiplos pontos de vista traições dante
os fortes um final épico mas na verdade
tudo isso era para dar espaço para
problemas reais os matamento melhor a
sua legal exploração sexual infantil
ameaça a povos indígenas hoje em dia
toda vez que a gente olha nosso futuro
através da indústria cinematográfica o
que que a gente ver a gente vê um futuro
distópico cinza com o melhor da
tecnologia e o pior o ser humano todo
mundo já viu blade runner netflix black
mirror the day after tomorrow a gente
conhece agora eu faço a pergunta
é responsável a gente lançar esse esse
imaginário coletivo
e para os nossos sonhos é assim que a
gente tem que imaginar nosso futuro
muito cuidado porque depois a gente pode
chegar nele as pessoas dizem que a
primeira coisa que tem que fazer quando
você quer muito uma coisa é sonhar com
ela sonhar coletivamente com futuro
verde próspero sustentável não é um
convite mais ahm urgência a gente fez
essa série numa cidade que se chama
manacapuru amazônia lá é uma explosão de
cores de vidas e histórias intimamente
ligadas a seu povo é muito importante
pensar nossa como comunicadores
sociedade global que essas 25 milhões de
pessoas que moram lá precisam de uma
alternativa de renda ligado sabe
economia que valorizem a floresta em pé
o desafio enorme mas depois vai ser
imenso ou nossa gratidão relação a isso
desde que eu era pequena muitas coisas
mudaram mas tem uma coisa
e quando eu visitava as vídeo locadoras
sempre encontrava os gêneros ação
comédia suspense terror esse gêneros não
mudaram eles continuam lá uma das nossas
pretensões com a série luan nas é criar
um novo gênero para estar junto a esses
o gênero ativista deixar um pouquinho de
lado os super-heróis e trazer aquela
pessoa ordinária o que você acha
ordinária fazendo coisas extraordinárias
e com isso trazer inspiração ao invés do
medo trazer solução ao invés da
paralisia trazer abundância ao invés de
qualquer paranoia que esse mundo moderno
hoje nos infrinjam é amor é acolhimento
e a mágica da contação das histórias
para escuta das histórias não existem
respostas fáceis mas existem sim
soluções reais uma coprodução entre a
maria farinha filmes e a tv globo que
fala com 100 milhões de pessoas
diariamente foi incrível e ambientar
essa série dentro de um espaço que
circunscreve nove países e é essencial
para o futuro da humanidade foi uma
escolha consciente 65 por cento da nossa
floresta nativa ainda está intacta e
isso porque os nossos guardiões da
floresta existem são corajosos e
destemidos são ativistas a gente
e aí
e quando a gente trabalha junto a gente
não tá só preservando uma floresta ea
sua biodiversidade a gente também está
preservando um patrimônio cultural
mundial por exemplo na amazônia a gente
está falando de 247 as línguas indígenas
faladas por 305 etnias todo mundo pode
progredir todo mundo pode ter lucro todo
mundo pode gerar impacto positivo é uma
questão de desejo uma questão de querer
aruana é a primeira produção
cinematográfica feita no brasil que
atende as premissas do sistema b licor
que que significa isso significa que a
gente neutralizou a nossa pegada de
carbono a gente prestou atenção a gente
reciclo noventa porcento do nosso
figurino a gente deu um emprego para 38
por cento dos locais que moram na
amazônia e o mais importante dos 200
profissionais contratados para fazer
parte da nossa equipe cinquenta por
cento eram mulheres
g1
e aí
é ficcional sim porém todos nós sabemos
que existem muitas aruana espalhadas
pelo planeta e elas precisam de nosso
apoio do nosso respeito preciso de
visibilidade o brasil é o país que mais
mata ativistas no mundo oitenta por
cento dessas mortes são de eco ativistas
porque a gente está matando porque
estamos matando aqueles que protegem o
nosso futuro o nosso futuro eo futuro
dos nossos filhos durante as filmagens
durante esses quatro meses a gente
encontrou uma forma de se conectar com
esses ativistas que foram assassinados
e na ordem do dia que todo mundo
receberá diariamente que falava que cena
a gente filmar aqui atores fazer um
parte onde a gente colocou uma foto de
uma ativista e uma biografia deles era
uma um gesto uma forma de se conectar
com eles de dar para ele de oferecer
para eles a nossa diária de filmagem
cheia de trabalho duro de alegria e de
amor
e para a gente trazer mudança que a
gente tem que superar em breve a gente
tem que trabalhar junto com o poder da
inovação e da criatividade da cultura de
paz na consciência energética e também
abraçando a cada gesto cada voz cada ser
vivo e talvez um atalho para isso seja
descobrindo o ativista que mora em cada
um de nós obrigado
[Aplausos]
e aí